a mere report this morning pinpoints
dangerous conditions that have
apparently led to many deaths in
facilities known as surgery centers
across the u.s. the report by USA Today
Network and kaiser Health News takes an
in-depth look at operations performed at
these non hospital facilities it found
more than 260 patients have died after
surgery Center procedures since 2013
Tony Duke opal is here with what the
investigation shows Tony good morning
good morning a lot to this investigation
surgery centers focus on routine
same-day operations and the industry
says this can make for cheaper faster
and more convenient service and in a
hospital but when something goes wrong
during surgery the hospital may be the
safer option I said go get him but
that's the last thing I said time there
was no reason for Scott and Sandy Velde
haizen to think they'd have to say
goodbye when their 12 year old son
Reuben had his tonsils removed in 2016
our surgeon said this is not going well
I just don't see it coded and they
called the ambulance an ambulance
because the procedure wasn't at a
hospital but at one of more than 5600
surgery centers across the u.s. there
are now more surgery centers than there
are hospitals we were watching them work
on our boy and one nurse would talk to
us and then the doctor said it was done
a federal report shows a paramedic who
arrived to treat Reuben received no
response from the facility staff when
she inquired who is in charge of CPR in
response to a lawsuit the center and one
of its doctors claimed Reubens death was
the result of pre-existing conditions
acts of others or conditions over which
they had no control or responsibility
the case was uncovered by a joint USA
Today Network and kaiser Health News
investigation which suggests surgery
centers aren't always prepared for a
crisis we had reporters in multiple
states who are digging through court
records digging through autopsies
digging through EMS records Cristina
Jewett was
of those reporters their investigation
turned up more than 260 deaths in
surgery centers since 2013 ranging from
the dozens who've died after routine
procedures like colonoscopies and
tonsillectomies to at least 14 people
who died after more complex spine
surgeries the majority of the cases go
great in these facilities but what we
found was that some of the patients are
not appropriate for the setting they
might be too sick some of the surgeries
might be too complicated and we also
found that sometimes the centers just
aren't prepared the report shows
inspectors have discovered 230 lapses in
rescue equipment or training regulations
at surgery centers since 2015
this report is doing a disservice to
patients bill Prentiss heads the
ambulatory surgery center Association
which represents these facilities if you
took that water view and looked at the
number of adverse events that happen in
hospitals compared to surgery centers
you'd see that we're in actually a very
safe site of service he says the fact
that 90% of these centers are at least
partially owned by physicians gives them
greater responsibility for everything
that happens there CBS News chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook
works at an outpatient facility that
closely follows the standards of a
hospital issue we asked if patients
should worry about doctors financial
interests
I think if patients are being
recommended to an outpatient surgical
facility it's a perfectly reasonable
question to say are you a part owner of
that and if the answer is yes well then
you have to perhaps go back and forth
about do I really need this why am i
doing it in this facility versus another
facility is it just too safe for me to
do it in the outpatient setting as the
inpatient setting perhaps the most
high-profile surgery center death was
that of Joan Rivers who stopped
breathing during a procedure in 2014 her
daughter Melissa filed a malpractice
suit claiming doctors took cell phone
pictures of the sedated star and fumbled
their response to the crisis the two
sides reached a settlement in 2016 the
USA Today Network and kaiser Health News
team had to dig hard to learn about the
cases we hadn't heard about it shouldn't
take a national team of investigative
journalists to answer these basic
questions there really should be
something for patient
to turn to to find out what is the
safest center in my area
Fred disagrees we need a better system
for reporting problems and a simpler way
for patients to compare the price and
quality of care we're not about trying
to hide from you know an adverse event
because the only way you're gonna learn
from it and improve it and make sure it
never happens again is by making sure
people know about it now of course there
are risks associated with any procedure
wherever it happens and if you're
considering surgery doctor or a surgery
center doctor LaPook recommends asking
about backup plans in case something
goes wrong and looking how long it would
take to get you to a hospital if it's a
long distance and your underlying health
is poor you might just want to have that
procedure at the hospital the first
place that's very good advice indeed as
I'm sitting you're thinking what do you
do because you like the cost of it and
you hear people say it's safe and then
on the other hand when something goes
wrong in a routine procedure that's very
scary what everyone seems to agree on is
that more data is needed to determine
which of these are the best centers
that's the thing you're always trying to
figure out get more data about your
underlying issue itself and then to have
to get more data about where you get
that issue taken care of more
complicated very interesting